c'est le genre de femme quand elle est
contrariée
elle peint du rouge pour la colère du
bleu dès que ça va mieux
du jaune quand elle sourit à nouveau
l'expo s'appelle d'ailleurs contrariété
une série de tableaux qui marient le
pinceau avec des motifs de tissus
africains des images des bouts de
phrases ou des articles de presse sur
quatre oeuvres maîtresses j'ai ciblé des
sujets qui nous conte sera riait mais
sur le reste de l'exposition je
travaillais sur le mot contrariété
essais signés j'en ai trouvé à peu près
42 dont la langue française et je les ai
appliqué sur différentes séries de
toiles ces essais synonymes et j'ai
essayé de les contrer de l'es2 les
conjurés avec des couleurs chatoyantes
ou alors avec des symboles textile que
j'ai retrouvé dans les adhérents
ce sont les ingrats ce sont des tissus
de la région d'afrique de l'ouest je
suis issu sont des tissus produit par le
groupe ethnique à caen qu'on retrouve au
ghana et en côte d'ivoire
aya n'est pas de yopougon mais elle est
aussi ivoirienne que la célèbre héroïne
de bande dessinée il y à 12 ans elle
débarque à pointe à pitre et travaille
comme anesthésiste à l'hôpital puis elle
découvre la peinture dans l'atelier d'un
plasticien guadeloupéen qu'il initie au
passo la lecture de ses oeuvres détient
une profondeur qui est qui qui en fait
la richesse c'est à dire qu on s'arrête
pas simple aspect séduisant visuel mais
on va chercher effectivement à la fois
comment c'est fait qu'est-ce que comment
les éléments aussi divers que la
tradition africaine que les pratiques
des plasticiens contemporains peuvent
s'associer à la fois peintre et médecins
aya regarde doublement la vie en face
l'artiste réveille chez cette femme tout
ce que l'anesthésiste andorre ici
parfois lui n'empiète sur l'autre pas de
problème car elle sait qu'il ne faut
jamais blâmer une contrariété